[Musik]
ich bin heute zu besuch bei jörg ehrlich
und otto drögsler von rd und so viel mag
gesagt sein mit der straßenbahn kommt
man hin schon nicht hinten
[Musik]
dann suchen wir die beiden ein
wir sehen nicht nur unseres erfolgs
geworden der seine bessere hälfte
da ist im haus glauben erlebt ihr so
versteckt hier es hat schon gar nicht
vermutet in dem dorf nicht vermuten
resistiv total abgeschiedenheit und ein
kleinod ist herzlich willkommen
richter stellen kann ihn ja ich hab's
eingehalten ist ein bisschen sehr kalt
draußen willkommen wir freuen uns es
gibt immer den mantel und jetzt warm
genug danke
zusätzlich wurde möchte ich eigentlich
nicht will kann man nicht sagen
so kam es dass hiernach die stadt
gezogen seit das liegt 20 jahre zurück
mit laura das war seit 98 immer man soll
ja mama oder anderen rand eigentlich
total auf stadt fixiert weil wir sie
münchen und düsseldorf kommen und neben
überhaupt nicht gefallen haben anfang
aber war dann als ich die tür zum garten
geöffnet ab sofort wird das nie
entwickeln bietet aussehen cooler master
und dann punkt
so eine ruhe wie hier habe ich noch nie
erlebt kommt aber natürlich nicht tor
und büssten anderen weltgegend wirklich
jeden tag ein kleiner urlaub
[Musik]
wer hier wirklich überall in jeder ecke
so viel schöne kunst zu finden ist einer
von euch der größere sammler
wir sammeln eigentlich beide also wie
geht es mit irgendwas kleine immer los
und dann entsteht die ruckzuck irgendwie
eine sammlung rosen postkarten bücher
das gibt mir sparschwein sammlung
irgendwann haben wir schon gefragt haben
sie auf händen
aber er gibt es ja dann auch
streitpunkte zwischen euch beiden dass
ihr seid bitte nicht schon wieder eine
hand oder eigentlich spaß spielen das
ging ja nichts an
bei der großen zeit gesammelt und bei
den rosen fragt er mich ja auch nicht
gefällt wenn sich immer alles gleich gut
aber irgendwie einigen wir uns wir
gucken wir alles mit dem gleichen augen
würden so einfach gefallen also haben
wir die dinge von dir dinge von mir dass
man mit den dingen älter wird und eben
gibt es ganz viele dinge die uns schon
sehr sehr glücklich
[Musik]
hier geht es ja schon los
ab dann auch ein lieblingsobjekt das
wechsel ständig aber so 1 was so
konstant eigentlich immer so da ist ist
dieses schriftliche anders ist das haben
wir in new york versteigert ich fand es
irgendwie so skurril inmitten dieser
ganzen minimalen kunst sie da hängt dass
wir das unbedingt haben wollten wir
geben vielen dingen die bühne geht ist
vielleicht manchmal gar nicht so
objektiv verdient es ist dann verbringe
tägliche kochen wenn wir hier sind
kommenden wochenende ohne kaufen gibt es
eigentlich
wir haben natürlich auch für das tolle
am landleben ist die tatsache dass wenn
jemand kommt dann bleibt er meistens
sogar das wochenende
deshalb ist auch die küche so konzipiert
dass du den gästen bist hier arbeite ich
wenn ich nicht vollkommen zurückziehen
möchte dass der firma und freiheits
sachen mache hier habe ich die ruhe bin
nicht abgelenkt wo er schaffte er dann
eigentlich eine installation extrem aus
dem alltag irgendwie reisen wir gucken
uns irgendwie alles an und wir hoffen so
dinge auch ab also ist manchmal so dass
wir auch ein ding zum anlass nehmen für
eine neue kollektion als zwei jahre
zurückliegt im prinzip sind gedanken
archiv wo wir uns immer wieder mit ihnen
können wenn ihr euch mit einem wort
verewigt
[Musik]
wenn ihr euch gegenseitig beschreiben
würde
mit drei wörtern dann werde ich hier
geschrieben als wahnsinnig inclusive
spontan und sehr mutig otto ist
unfassbar kreativ das gilt für zwei
eigenschaften ich kenne keinen menschen
der aus sich heraus so viel
künstlerisches und kreatives auch für
unseren jobs schafft und er ist ein
extrem harmonie bedürftiger gelassener
zeit genauso im partner genieße ich sehr
so seht ihr euch dann 90 das hat unseren
niemand gestellt offen gestand ich weiß
ich weiß es nicht also ich glaube was
tun also ich sehe mich nicht im
liegestuhl auf bali oder sie haben dabei
den nicht dieses fernseh in dir zu
arbeiten aufhören sollten dass wir dann
müssen dafür machen wir das was wir
machen irgendwie zu gerne sie ja schon
schwierig die frage in einem fünf jahres
blick zu beantworten also keine armen
dafür leben den zur dynamisches leben
und so lange sie morgen also ich bin mir
sicher was ihr macht das klappt auf
jeden fall anders
ich denke nach
[Musik]
ok